how does the book business differ to the
film business it's it well what what
I've noticed is
in the book world there's um
not a lot of people are there for all
the for all the huge amounts of cash
coming in there there's kind of more of
a a passion like oh crap we might have
picked the wrong thing but this is what
we love
so
when I'm working with like an editor I'm
working with an agent there's a deep
love you know the agent wants to make
money then you know these people yeah
they do want to make money but they're
kind of there
because it's uh it's just what what they
what they know and what they're good at
uh when we get to film there's a there's
a little bit more uh
you know the film business is um
weird I I I I really don't connect with
the film business that much at all I'm
not good at the film business
um and
so it's uh I'm kind of not even good at
pitching you know I'm not good there's a
lot of things I'm really not good at on
the film side of things but um
but I know but I know that I know the I
know my the story is the only thing that
really that I really care about and then
the
maniacal passion to get it out there
when I feel like I've got it right so
and and I've you know people in the
people in the film business they're nuts
they're just absolutely nuts
um and it and what I've learned is it's
just hilarious how people are like oh
yeah no that's I'm Indie you know we
will never do Studio work and it's like
oh we're studio and it's just like there
are pieces of crap on every single layer
and sometimes those Indie sometimes
those Indie focused people are the ones
you don't want to work with at all to be
much better to work at Paramount and
sometimes it's vice versa there's um
the game is just funny there's just uh
what I've learned is
um
you know what what I've learned in my my
small career so far is to uh
is to just love who you work with and
but in the film industry that might not
be an option and have a really good
entertainment lawyer that spells
everything out and you don't even have
to talk to some people sometimes even if
you're working with them just so
well that was going to be my next
question is can you love film and love
you know wanting to put something out
there but not love the business and not
really want to be a part of the business
does that it seems like that can't work
out well I'd love to be a part of the
business where the checks are big that's
my favorite part of the business I would
love to be a part of that
um
hey the business needs to be done and I
understand why the business needs to be
done I mean to create a film is a
Monumental expense and people are
putting their money and going okay let's
make profit and um
so the stakes are very high
and
it's you know I nobody knows what's
going to make it what you know or like
William Gold was it William Goldman or
just like nobody knows anything but they
make good guesses
and there's a lot of people that make
good guesses
um
I I do I mean I love the art of film I
you know I love the passion of someone
who's in wardrobe and to talk to someone
who does wardrobe and and it's just like
they are storytellers there and
I've learned a lot coming into this
where my uh
you know I've Loved film before I love
it even more now that I've seen behind
the curtain so that yeah there's the
business part but but most of this most
of the time if you're really working on
something the business part's so
secondary and you you try to get agents
and entertainment lawyers to do all of
that part of it and then go okay great
here's what I need to do and this is
what I need to deliver and I think a lot
of that is communication too I'm I think
I've learned a lot over the years be
very almost over communicative so they
know what to expect so they know what I
can bring and don't promise anything
that I can't bring but let them know
that I'm going to try to do that but
that might be out of my realm but let's
just see what happens kind of thing so
so then with the literary World maybe
New York old money sort of this this
closed network is that a fallacy it's
much more open now it's it's oh I don't
know yeah um I just might be with the
cool people okay
um I mean
I I don't know in the publishing end I
guess I know just a lot of writers so uh
who you know are just lovely people
whether they're a bestseller every time
they come out or they're on a
you know small print run and I love
both of their styles of writing equally
and love them you know in their own ways
as people so I think maybe I know more
the writing end and I get to kind of be
aloof to the to where the business is I
kind of just don't I don't care too much
and you know I'm dealing with publicists
a lot because I cover writers and the
publicists are great too for the most
part you know they're just passionate
about the the writing and they're they
want to get their they want to get their
authors out there and
um which publicist I've worked with for
20 years you know that that uh they they
know who to give me they just go you're
going to love this guy and I'm like
great you're gonna love this girl I'm
like great I don't even need to see the
book just just yeah they're on the
calendar
so um the the passion for it is there I
want to talk to writers you know I'd say
I want to talk to Ryan that's the lovely
thing of doing
a podcast is uh someone you know if I
went hey I want to talk to you to just
that random out of the blue they'd be
like who who are you you have a podcast
and you're like I'd love to talk to that
person for an hour and pick their brain
and it's just like wait you can just do
it it's just it's good fun isn't that
strengths with Tony yeah
and you've been doing it how long the
next year will be 20 years so I'm
putting together the 20-year anniversary
party but I did have the Hiatus for five
years between 2013 and 2018. so why the
Hiatus that's when Jesus jerk went into
development and then I had to get to La
and I used to do drinks with Tony in
studio in San Francisco so that was that
was a two-hour show in studio and I
didn't know how to do it not in studio
and then after all the film that for the
film was released and that kind of
um
that the kind of dust settled then I
went maybe I should just do this as a
podcast and have my field recording gear
instead of worrying about
being a doing a two-hour show so I just
kind of switched up the format
the way you miss writing and the way you
feel like you're a better person for
writing and when you don't it's kind of
like the people that meditate they're
like oh if I don't meditate I'm not fun
to be around were you similar with not
being able to do the podcast
did you need did you miss that did you
need to do that podcast
so well uh so after after Jesus jerk
came out and after all the dust settled
I was walking up Hillhurst
totally depressed
I just gutted I didn't know why and I'm
like how do I get out of this depression
and I'm like what's the last thing that
made me happy as I was like you know as
I was working on other writing projects
and stuff but and I went drinks with
Tony
and I think I think because there's no
stakes in it from you there's stakes in
it because I want to do a good show
but there's no there's not the stakes
that I'm putting into my writing and at
the same time
and I and I restarted it with thinking
oh maybe I'll get 10 episodes in I
wasn't planning on doing it that long I
was just like oh I still got this and I
got public publicist contacts I'll just
tell people I'm doing it again and then
when I don't get a guess I'll just stop
and um I just put episode 157 up because
the guests haven't stopped coming and I
have to say no to a lot of people so
it's just like oh um but and I still
enjoy it and the only reason I do it is
because I really enjoy it it's you know
the one in ten guests I go ugh that that
felt like a piece of crap but you know
the nine out of ten I'm just like oh
this is why I do this and there's like
two out of ten where I'm like this is
really why I do this this is this
reminds me of why I'm in this game so
whereas with writing if you don't write
explain to me how long before you suffer
withdrawal
um it's I think it's um I think I think
the thing the thing is is I need to have
characters in my brain and I need
characters
that are coming together
um so I I need to actively be working on
someone so I'm working on a character
Amber right now and so in the during the
day I can have things that irritate me
but I have the problem solving of how
will Amber get out of this situation who
what is Amber what else does what else
does she need
um what what is what does she want to
say to the world so it's it's maybe it's
a way to avoid the the conflict
happening around me where I can kind of
almost meditate on this character that
I'm working on and this you know that I
may that this character actually kind of
don't like but as I'm writing her I'm
writing her completely out of love and
just building around her and you know
she's she's a yeah I mean what you know
this is this is uh yeah this is a writer
in process on a character but this
character does not make great choices
and this character continues to make
great choices and in the end she still
doesn't make the great choice
she's so there's
um but working with her and kind of
really getting in her head is just a lot
of fun and just
um and what swirls around her uh is I
find interesting why do you love her if
she makes these bad choices
um I'm well I'm setting up a it's
there's another character that I'm
working on that's gonna get the um a
that's going to be more of the
protagonist
and uh
it's a story of three characters but
there's this one character that is more
pivotal than the others so the
characters are around him need to really
be
three-dimensional and now and I also
want you know I love the ambiguity of in
my head she's not making the right
choices but as we get you know as we get
as we move through the story
maybe she is making the right choices
it's it's uh you know it well in the end
she's doing the best she can with the
information she has
but as far as I'm concerned it's that
character is someone that's not
um that's not that hasn't reached the
maturity or reached a certain level of
understanding but has stayed in it and
so I have empathy for that and that's uh
so yeah so driving here I'm I'm just
like driving and I'm thinking of Amber
and people are like oh who who's Amber
is that your girlfriend I'm like no it's
a it's just a word on a page but you
have a vision of what she looks like
what her hopes are what her fears are
what her triggers are yeah yeah yeah and
as I keep writing her I find out more
about her
um and that's that's the joy of
that's the joy of prose writing for me
because I can I can find out if I'm
as I write and I write the scene now and
I go oh
that's why she's doing that you know it
was
I had uh on this particular one in the
in the in the screenplay she's she's
looking in the mirror and reflecting on
herself and that was like the only thing
and as I wrote the thing out
um she's worried about aging
she's in her 20s and she's worried about
aging and um and it's and and that kind
of clicked and I went and it create it
opened her up and it opened the whole
story up in a new way
where it's just like I'm not going to
put in the screen now if it if if the if
the prose gets thrown away and it stays
in the screenplay I'm not putting in the
screenplay she's worried about aging but
I know she's worried about aging when
she looks in the mirror
she's a model or cocktail waitress or
makeup artist oh okay all right yeah
okay do you ever see her anywhere do you
ever see like oh that was Amber no no I
didn't no I I don't see her I see her
enough I mean when I'm writing the
script you just I see her enough and I
don't want to cast her
um I I like that to be very open but I
do have my thoughts on certain things
um
but as far as like describing exactly
who she is and what she looks like
there's there's just little Composites
here and there and um and I'll take out
like pages from like uh magazines and
stuff and it's there's you know there's
an idea but it's not that but it's there
could be something that um
you know a certain a certain photograph
is just like oh that's kind of an
essence of what she could be
um and yeah it's I'm not one to really
describe I I don't care much about what
they look like I care more about the
insides I guess and then for the film
it's you know there's casting directors
for that who could tell me way better
who could they're much better with at
that gig than I am so